President Trump says adieu tax law is
boosting the economy he writes in this
morning's USA Today on this tax day
America is strong and roaring back
paychecks are climbing the tax rates are
going down businesses are investing in
our great country and most important the
American people are winning Larry Kudlow
was appointed director of the National
Economic Council last month he'll be
involved in the president's summit with
japan's Prime Minister and mar-a-lago
that starts today this is his first
Network TV interview as a part of the
Trump administration Larry Kudlow good
morning mr. director I want to start
thank you the question of the tax cut
bill when it first was passed the White
House put out announcements of all the
bonuses that were being given out at
companies and that seems to have slowed
every dollar counts but for the broad
benefit across the economy Bank of
America and Merrill Lynch did a study
and found that only 45 of the 500
companies in the S&P 500 have paid out
cash bonuses the rest have put them into
stock buybacks and shareholder dividends
so give us your take on how the tax cut
is working its way into the economy well
I think it's doing really well I just
want to make one point share buybacks in
some cases but the biggest winner right
now is business investment that is huge
equipments technology software and so
forth
factories that's where the real nuts and
bolts of this thing the incentives at a
lower business tax rate both large and
small now on the Paycheck thing
look the bonuses are one thing and that
was great but don't forget withholding
rates are lower and the bracket ceilings
are higher so that's a combination of
fatter paychecks for every single
working America about a hundred and
fifty five million people so I think
we're off to a great start
you asked you about China where the
things stand and we've been there's been
talk of trade wars then some people have
said well maybe we're just in a kind of
negotiation stage here get a bring us up
to date will you I'll try look at it
it's certainly not a trade war I think
of it as a trade dispute I think both
countries would like to settle this
President Trump is good relationship
with pres
and she president she is a good able
negotiator look everything's on the
table we we can't let them keep stealing
American technology that's really the
nub of this that's what makes America
the greatest economy the most
entrepreneurial economy we can't let
that happen it's been going on for two
decades that said we'll see about the
tariffs we've made some proposals
nothing has been enacted yet I want to
make that point and it probably won't be
for several months perhaps the two sides
will be able to talk it through let's
see what happens so far though the
Chinese are coming back with more
constructive reactions so I'm optimistic
about that that will work things through
mr. Kudlow the latest poll shows that
only 27 percent of Americans think that
this tax bill is a good idea is that a
good enough number for you which polls
that Wall Street Journal yeah so let me
help you on The Wall Street Journal poll
I don't they're friends of mine
but that poll did not ask any registered
voters nor did it ask likely voters so I
got to say I'm not impressed with that
most of the polls that I've seen show
close to 50% support for the tax cuts
and mines you we're just really getting
started the paychecks and the
withholding rates as I said earlier
you've got the child tax credits the
doubling you've got a doubling of the
standard deduction you've got lower
income tax rates you've got lower
business tax rates I think it's a winner
I saw this morning Gallup poll Gallup
poll showed that let's see only 45% of
Americans now think they're taxed too
much that's the lowest number since the
JFK 1960's so I think we're on the right
track Larry it's good to see you you're
there in mar-a-lago for a meeting with
the Japanese Prime Minister Abe a today
he's been one of the presidents most
ardent supporters since election and yet
he hasn't been exempted from the steel
in aluminum tariffs the way other US
allies have I'm assuming he'll be asking
for that today will the president
deliver it to him well I don't want to
get ahead of my skis as some
people say it's going to be on the table
there'd be a lot of discussions here
economic cooperation trade cooperation
foreign policy cooperation this will be
part of the ongoing discussions
we'd like to pan to open up some markets
and help us particularly our agriculture
sector Japan is looking to coordinate
and integrate better with the United
States so we'll see it's a topic I don't
want to get ahead of the story though
we'll see how this works out how
President Trump decides to play it are
you advising him to do it quickly in the
last seconds here I wanted a good solid
trade deal with Japan Larry Kudlow thank
you so much